with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get them all so if you didn't see
building go applications for the open
cloud then stay tuned because here's the
rewind building a cloud native
application in our modern times means
embracing one key concept embrace the
open cloud this really means to write
your code application and systems such
that you can easily move it between
providers without needing to worry about
heavy lifting focusing on this let's
utilize the strengths of each cloud
provider well not being at the mercy of
vendor lock-in not to mention the
improved resilience against provider
downtime unfortunately this is much
easier said than done at a high level
most clouds look the same but at a low
level things are drastically different
each cloud has their own provider
specific services unique api's specific
semantics and in general a different
mental model about how to architect
deploy and manage your cloud native
application that can make for a lot of
differences kubernetes is one of the
tools that helps address this but it's
not a complete solution while kubernetes
does a great job at abstracting away the
underlying compute infrastructure
differences between providers it doesn't
extend into the realm of database
storage log aggregation runtime
configuration testing and so on and so
on so what do you do about all that
stuff well this is where go cloud
library comes in go cloud is an open
source project written entirely in
golang which provides generic api's for
commonly used services such as blob
storage runtime variables my sequel
database access and an HTTP server
configured with tracing request logging
and health checks using the abstraction
in go cloud lets you take your
application from being tightly
integrated into a specific cloud vendor
to a more open and generic platform this
removes very tight coupling and gives
your application better Portability and
flexibility and that's one of the ways
you can really embrace the open cloud to
help show off the power of go cloud the
talk dives into a live demonstration
Ross and Ino show off a step-by-step
walkthrough of how awesome the go cloud
project is so you'll definitely want to
check that out if you'd like to see the
full talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great
rewind content thanks for watching
you
[Music]